uh let's get started uh welcome everyone
to the Simon's Institute uh because many
of you are here long term but I know
there are also people coming here just
for this week so uh my name is venkat
guruswami I'm a senior scientist here at
the Simons Institute and it's my
pleasure to invite you all to this
Workshop
um a brief blurb about the Simon's
Institute
um for those who may not be yet familiar
which is you know probably likely crowd
in the theory Community but
um we are the leading venue for
collaborative research and theoretical
computer science in later areas and um
and this and every this was established
in 2012 with a generous Grant by the
sound the Simon's foundation and every
semester it brings together uh
um a lot of researchers in specific
areas widely varying areas of
theoretical computer science and this is
the 10th year of programs at Simon's and
we're really proud of the achievements
of the programs which have pushed the
frontiers of TCS in so many directions
they've resolved long-standing open
questions and I've also opened up new
lines of inquiry and each semester
program attracts around 70 long-term
visitors Junior and senior to Berkeley
and also includes a boot camp and three
workshops that convene more short-term
visitors
and I would like to welcome you to the
workshop on Lower bounds learning and
average case complexity which is the
first of three workshops in this
semester's program which focuses on meta
complexity and I would like to thank the
organizers of this workshop for their
work in putting together a great program
and they are Valentine cabinets I'm
sitting here and I'll hand it over to
him shortly and Igor Olivera
um who's here and Russell
uh who did the work but then he will be
here so and uh thanks everyone so the
organizers oh there's Russell okay let's
give them a round of applause
[Applause]
and uh a few logistics for the coming
week um the food is provided before the
first talk and during the breaks just
outside where you are now for lunch you
are on your own but there are many
excellent options in walking distance
and the weather I think will be good
this week
um and we do ask that you please leave
any food and drinks uh outside the
auditorium you know um water and Bottles
is okay but no beverages or food so that
keeps the auditorium clean and if you do
need to store something while you're
going for lunch like your backpack or
coats uh there are lockers on the other
side please use them and for all talks
omead far has here our videographer and
he will help you set up and any
questions you can ask him and I'm not
sure is this this Workshop is hybrid uh
okay if it is hybrid Zone if you are
here in the room of course ask questions
by just raising your hand and uh if you
are attending remotely I believe someone
will be monitoring and you can ask
questions on the chat okay and finally I
would like to give a thanks to the
organizing um the events Team without
whom the event would definitely not uh
happen uh Kalani Penland actually Hassan
and Elizabeth Ewan and they manage all
the logistics for the week including the
accommodations for out of town visitors
so I think let's give them an Applause
as well
with that I'll hand it over to Valentin
to introduce
thank you very much thank you for coming
and on behalf of uh Russell Igor myself
welcome to the workshop it's the first
Workshop in this year so three workshops
roughly on complexity logic and
cryptography and so this is a complexity
one and roughly connected to the theme
of meta complexity
um we have lots of talks
um the first day today is special day
um to honor Harry calendar who was doing
Commodore time-bound comma complexity
before it was cool
so now we have a special semester
thanks to people like him we have the
special semester at Simons that talk
about time-bound and Covergirl
complexity and matter complexity it has
lots of contributions to matter
complexity and theoretical computer
science some of whom will give talks
later today but we'll start with Rahul
santanam who'll talk about some of the
work that air calendar has done for meta
complexity so peace
foreign
so yeah it's really a privilege to be
here um today and to talk about Eric's
work
um so uh I mean as as Valentin said
Eric's WX work we couldn't really
imagine this program happening so
perhaps the most influential body of
work for this for this program
um and um so right from the beginning
when we wrote The Proposal we had
earmarked a day to celebrate Eric's work
and Communists chose this day and um so
tomorrow is Valentine's day but today is
the next day
um so um just to for those of you who
haven't been a semester so far just a
very kind of a quick slide about meta
complexity and what it is um just we're
all on the same page
um So Meta complexity studies the
complexity of problems that are
themselves about complexity and Prime
examples the known circuit size problem
and the problem complexity
um and well I mean this sort of these
questions have applications to a variety
of
um of other fields they have
applications to complexity low bounds of
course and are about complexity load
bonds but also the learning to average
case complexity cryptography and proof
complexity and we'll be hearing about
all of these connections through the um
through the semester we've already heard
about them during the boot camp
um but for this talk I'd like to kind of
like take a more historical perspective
which actually Eric already did to some
extent in his a cop lecture a couple of
weeks ago
um so computer science is a very sort of
a field that's quite obsessed with being
in the present and and the trends and so
on
um and medical blessing is opposite of
that because it's something that's been
uh that concerns foundational questions
that have been around for a very long
time without us making much progress and
even if we live in the present we need
the past understand explain the present
um So Meta complexity might have a lot
to say for the future of uh foundational
questions but questions what did we do
for converter complexities on what would
matter complexity do for us so here's
sort of a little bit about the history
of meta complexity
um so the pre-history of medicalplexity
so there are several papers that um sort
of talked about the complexity of
complexity sort of implicitly or in sort
of scattered ways without there really
being a coherent theory of this field
um so and I'd just like to say a little
bit about some of these papers so um
uh starting off with the work of
chronograph and Levin so right from the
beginning um I mean 11's work has been
very concerned with common ground
complexity using that as a tool to
understand competition and information
um so um right from this paper where he
proves the NP completeness of of various
problems including satisfiability one of
the other problems that he proves and to
complete himself is the version of the
circuit size problem
um for dnfs so that's um so that's
nearly 50 years ago and um then he
defined his notion of time-bound control
complexity and studied its properties
um then there's also actually a Berkeley
connection to meta complexity so the
first conference paper that the wazironi
brothers ever wrote was on meta
complexity so it's it's really a
question about a problem about
time-bound or complexity a sort of
restricted version of it they showed
that this version was NP complete under
randomized reductions and their
motivation was quite different they
weren't so much concerned with the
problem being important but they were
considered the power of randomized
reductions and they were interested in
finding a national problem that would be
and be complete and randomized
reductions but wasn't known to be NP
complete under the domestic reductions
so that was their motivation
um and I think it's not a very
well-known paper so I thought I'd kind
of highlight that
um there's um all this work in in the
Soviet Union in the 50s and 60s on meta
complexity which um wasn't really I
think well known in the west until maybe
truck and brought survey where he talked
about this work in the 50s and 60s even
predate in Congressman Levin
um there's uh the the famous paper of 11
about average case complexity and that
has a section on on meta complexity um
in a way there's course paper which is
about the hardness of proving NP
hardness of um of of matter complexity
and he gives like an oracle relative
which is not true so there's on the
paper it's perhaps not as well known as
it should be so there's various Works
sort of like scattered around but not
really I think like connecting with each
other or sort of like um trying to
establish um a kind of broader Theory
and then um there's these works in the
90s and and in 2000 so the roster of
rudish paper on National proofs was
extremely influential because even
though it didn't explicitly use the
language of meta complexity it was
really talking about that and it sort of
foreshadowed future links with a variety
of areas with the cryptography with
learning and proof complexity
um and then in 2000 uh Valentina defined
and studied the circuit modernization
problem mcsp so the first ones to Define
mcsp and and they kind of um had various
interesting results about this relevance
to complexity Theory especially
um so why is it hard to prove NP
hardness but also what kinds of
consequences would it have mcsps and P
so um so various results of that form
and that's really what I think um
settings in Motion in terms of studying
meta complexity more um in a more
focused way but it took a while
um and while it did I mean Eric was uh
was publishing a lot of papers on better
complexity um so um uh yeah so let's
kind of like
look at some of these
[Music]
yeah so there's this kind of paper which
is a survey in FSG TCS in 2001 and
that's
um so as you see there's a lot of papers
that Eric wrote and I when I Was
preparing for this talk and thinking
about what I'd say there's a question of
how to best sort of summarize or discuss
his contributions should I sort of like
do like a highlight store
um I finally decided it would be best to
focus on this one paper because that's
as far as I can tell the earliest people
wrote about metaplexity and for me at
least it's been very influential I think
as you'll see I'll kind of like explain
how it connects to various lines of work
in our area so that's what I'm doing but
I did want to kind of um show you a list
of papers that he wrote um I mean he was
publishing constantly through the early
2000s especially
um this is kind of apart from random
strings paper on the paper that's been
very influential
um this paper in which they defined
other Notions of complexity
um then there's this whole program that
he had about which language is
officially reducible to the random
strings and various resource bounded
versions of it so this is part of that
paper here's a paper with Tony and Mike
and others on the mcsp problem
restricted to dnfs and constant depth
circuits here's a survey that he did
um and uh yeah another survey several
other papers so as you'll see he was
constantly publishing through um through
the early 2000s at a time when not many
other people were
um in fact I have a sort of conjecture
to make it's a historical conjecture
that I haven't been able to verify but
as far as I can tell between like 2001
and 2012 100 of papers in medical
complexity had Eric as an author on them
and even if it isn't quite true it's
approximately true I think um so um so
he was advocating for it and kind of
like and clearly um working on it but
um it wasn't yet able to convince people
other people to work on it with him or
um uh in in their own right and um
people did eventually listen but it took
a while
um so yeah what I'm going to be focusing
on is this is this paper so um it's a
fairly short paper it's a survey more or
less an fsgtc so it's disguised to the
survey as I'll argue it has lots of
interesting things to say sort of new
connections to make
um new theorems which are disguised with
observations
um and uh kind of uh suggestions for
further directions and so on
um so it's it's actually quite a rich
paper
um
um and I'd like to um kind of bring it
to people's attention more and and to
talk about how it connects to carbon day
work so um here's like the the title and
Abstract of the paper so um
um yeah this paper is the following
goals to survey some of the recent
developments in the field of V
randomization to introduce a new notion
of time-bound control complexity K
capital T and sure it provides a useful
tool for advancing for understanding
advances in determinization
um to illustrate the usefulness and to
pose some promising directions for
future research so yeah very modest
abstract
um
so and that's I mean but it's a sort of
grand title and kind of like um yeah and
um and and indeed it connects sort of
like very areas that don't seem really
that closely connected and so it
showcases the importance of Monroe
complexity in these areas so in a way
the stock is going to be a commentary on
the paper so I'm going to kind of like
discuss what the paper does and sort of
um how it connects to uh to what's
happened since
um so there's these various things that
the paper does right it sort of
introduces and motivates A New Concept
the concept of K capital T complexity it
finds these new characterizations of
well-known complexity questions in terms
of variants of strong growth complexity
and then it proves this sort of new low
bound proves or observes a new low bound
and it points the way to several others
um and it identifies various interesting
open problems and directions
um so there's there are Concepts there
are new connections and
characterizations there are new results
New open problems directions and I want
to kind of like talk about how all of
this um how various lines of work
nowadays can be traced back to tube
themes in this paper
so let's start off with what K capital P
complexity is and and um and in order to
talk about that let me say a bit about
what meta complexity problems
um we can Define just based on standard
Notions of circuit size and more
complexity so if you haven't
um really you know seen meta complexity
very much so here are some fundamental
problems about complexity
um minimum circuit size problem given
the truth table of a Boolean function f
and a parameter s does f for Boolean
circuits of size s
um so that's yeah perhaps the main
problem of the area
um then there are all these versions of
commodore complexity so there's plain
color complexity where
um you're asking given a string and a
parameter does a string have complexity
at most that
um and here the control complexity is
the minimum program size to produce that
string from um from an empty input you
can also Define conditional versions
where this input here is a string Y and
then you're asking for the smallest
program to produce X from y
um and then there's a time-bounded
version where you have some a priority
time bound let's say n to the 100 and
you want to know whether there's a
program that produces X from um end time
n to the 100 n is the size of X
um so T is a polynomial bounded function
we've we fix in advance and we want to
know whether you can produce X
efficiently and this seems more relevant
to complexity Theory because there's a
problem in NP you can guess the program
and then you can check that it produces
X within polynomial time
and then there's a k-cap little T notion
which is defined by 11. um so given a
string and a parameter s is scalability
at most s and how is scality defined
well it might not seem very intuitive at
first so
um essentially you take the program size
and then you add like a further term to
it in this case it's
um sort of a logarithmic term in t
um and yeah it's not clear why
logarithmic is the right function and as
you'll see Eric makes a different Choice
when it defines K capital T complexity
so the minimum over program size plus
log of the time bounds such that U of P
comma Epsilon outputs X within T steps
right and the significance of this
notion is it somehow captures the
complexity of search for Witnesses it
kind of um can be used to argue for like
an optimal algorithm for searching for
Witnesses
um of of NP problems
um but yeah we won't get into the
motivation here this is just kind of an
interesting notion of from raw
complexity so there's various Notions
here and um one of them isn't like the
others right so three of those Notions
that are really about Commodore
complexity and mcsp isn't it's defined
in terms of circuit size
so it's clear that mcsp is a problem
about compression I mean circuits are
compressions of Truth tables compressed
representations of Truth tables
um so one could ask is there a natural
sort of column grab like complexity
measure so complexity measure based on
um on some sort of like um on standard
criminal complexes some variant of it
that can be used to characterize
understand MCS online question yes
um yeah so is there an actual like
complexity measure that can be used to
characterize understand mcsb
um
and um here's what we can notice so
um if you're asking um about mcsp you
want to know whether why is the truth
table a function you want to know if it
has small circuits well a circuit C for
f can be thought of as a program for y
that can be used to compute y locally
right so
um a circuit is a program such that
given any bit of Y you can kind of
recover that bit from the program in
time proportional or slightly more than
the circuit size you just run C on I the
binary representation of I and that
gives you the bit y i so
um it is kind of a program but a program
where kind of like the competition um
kind of happens in a local way for why
um so that sort of maybe gives us a hint
about what to do and um and Eric made
this definition so K capital P and the
capital P is because time plays a bigger
role in this definition it's sort of
this there's a larger Factor Depending
on time
um than for K level T and that's the
reason for K capital T so so minimum of
program size plus time such at U of P
comma I outputs the ith but x sub I here
is the output within T steps right
um and you should really be thinking of
p is sublinear here right because X can
be computed with the program of length
size of X or slightly more we're just
sort of like um to Output the output of
X you just look at the ith bit of the
program right so so that's like a
trivial way to compute X you really
would know what you can do with smaller
time bounds with sublinear time bounds
with small programs
um
and um so Eric proves that K capital T
of Y for any string Y and the circuit
size of f sub y which is just the the
function the Boolean function
corresponding to Y you can assume that Y
is a string of length say 2 to the N
maybe truncating it to the first to its
to the largest part of two smaller than
the length of Y so you can just kind of
make sure that Y is the length of power
has length of power of 2 and then that
corresponds to a Boolean function whose
truth table Y is that's F sub y and the
circuit size of this function f sub y
and K capital T of Y are probably
related to each other right so so it
sort of really capturing circuit
complexity or a good approximation to
Circuit complexity
um and that's not very hard to prove um
based on what I said before about local
computation if you have a circuit
um that computes FY then that can be the
program and the time taken by the
program is sort of proportional to the
Circuit size so you get some sort of
approximation Factor there and the other
direction if there's a program
um that computes um y sort of implicitly
in this way locally um then um just by
using the simulation of time by circuits
you can get circuit out of it right so
both directions aren't hard to show but
it's an important notion
um
um and one could ask is it a natural
notion that relates to previously
defined resource bounded variants of
congrof complexity and it turns out as
was shown by that so I should have
mention that left Ronald Berger who
showed this that
um if a is any language complete for
linear exponential time under efficient
reductions under linear time reductions
then K capital T to the a so you can
define an oracle version where this
Universal machine has access to an
oracle a so if you have Oracle uh an
expression time language a complete
language then that is within a linear
factor of kldp so really
um K Little T is kind of um fundamental
even though it is defined last
um and in fact if a is say a linear
space complete language then you get the
space bounded version of Blackstreet
um so it does relate to
um the the previously defined measures
but um it might still ask well what's
the point of klt why should we care
about K capital T rather than circuit
size
and one major reason is we don't
understand the circuit size of random
Boolean function on end bits as well as
we would like
so um a very long time ago lupinov show
the circuit size is is this quantity
um but it's not as good
um and as I mean it's pretty good but um
it doesn't like capture the expected
circuits as a random function to within
say a good additive term so we don't
know what it does precisely and the
variance isn't as small as we'd like and
it's far less precise than understanding
of raw complexion is variance because
for all the versions of common law
complexity we have each string of X of
length n has complexity at most n plus
log n plus order one in fact for most
variance it's n plus order one for K
capital t is n plus log n plus order one
so each string has a small description
um in terms of its length and most
strings have large descriptions right so
um if you look at the
um the property that a string um has
complexity at most n minus K it's like a
geometric distribution all but one or
two to the K fractional strings of
length then have complexity at least n
minus K and that's my simple counting
argument so um most strings are
complexity very close to um to the max
month and in fact this has been key in
some more recent work connecting from
World complexity to cryptography
um so this is this is very nice and we'd
like to um have something as close to
this property as possible for circuit
sites but we don't know how to so
there's more precise understanding of
compressibility
um for control complexity and its
variants allows us to prove Tighter and
more results for the meta-complexity
version of K capital T right so circuit
size as this matter complexity problem
mcsp similarly we can define a meta
complexity version of K capital P and um
and and this sort of like more kind of
precise understanding of K Capital
allows us to prove better results and
we'll see how now so what's MK Capital
PP is given a string X and a parameter s
you ask is K capital T of X at most um s
right so um is is the K capital D
complexity at most yes
um and here just like a couple
um yeah a couple of results which show
why MK Capital TP is like a good notion
to try to
um approach results about mcsp right so
if you have a result about mcsp that you
want to establish
um it seems that a good strategy is to
try to prove it for Mk Capital TP first
because it's more tractable or it's
easier to analyze
um so it was shown in a paper of Eric
and trichy and then a paper of sushi and
me that um that MK Capital TP is not an
a0 mod P for any Prime P so a low bound
um against ac01 P but showing the same
logo of mcsp was not a much harder
question
um and then um Valentine um Russell
Anthony Longo and others um kind of
showed that um this uh was in indeed the
case um that mcsp was not an s0 mod P
um and the proof there was more
complicated so um it did require a bit
more work than this proof so this kind
of like gives us a sense that maybe this
result holds and maybe points the way
towards some ideas but then more work is
required um to complete the proof for
mcsp
e so this is a case where a result of
mcsp was shown by first showing a
similars of MK Capital PP and then kind
of yeah maybe building on or kind of
bringing some new ideas
and there's several other cases where we
know the result for Mk capital P but we
don't know it for mcsp and whether do a
from CSP is still open so I mean I guess
these are all kind of like open
questions in a way for this for this
program so cases where they're kind of
like yeah kind of important results that
we want to show
um so one result for example that
showing evidence for the hardness of
these problems right so we know that um
these problems just from raspberry
rubrics we know that these problems are
hard if one-way functions exist so under
standard cryptographic assumptions we
know that they're one that they're hard
um but can we show hardness under other
assumptions average case hardness
assumptions
um so it was shown that MK Capital TP is
hard under say the planted click
hypothesis
um and under fiber's hypothesis on
average case hardness of KSAT so um
these are um sort of average case
hardness assumptions
um yeah that are not sort of like
implied by the existence of one-way
functions
and we don't know this for mcsp so um we
know these we know that MK Capital PP is
hard we don't know what mcsp is hard I
mean it seems absurd that MK Capital TP
um could be uh um hard but mcsp not
right they're so closely related but as
far as we know we can't rule out the
possibility that
um MK Capital PP is NP hard and mcsp
isn't p as far as I know so
um we still don't kind of understand the
relationship between these problems very
well but we do expect that similar
results hold for them
so that's one example of something we
don't know for mcsp and would like to
know
um then um the result of 100 ran I
showed that MK capital P is hard on
average with uniform distribution so you
kind of choose a string from the uniform
distribution and you want to know you
ask the argument computers K capital T
complexity
um or to decide a state cavity
complexity and um for a certain notion
of hardness mild average case hardness
it turns out this is the case if and
only if there's a one-way function
computable in nc1
um so it's really a characterization of
parallel cryptography the average case
harness of this problem which I think
again motivates it motivates the notion
and um shows that it's important on the
other hand we don't yet have a good
characterization of average case harness
of mcsp or the uniform distribution
that's like a long standing open problem
to try to do that there are some partial
results but um it's still not clear
exactly what characterization is and the
barrier is precisely what I said before
but the fact that we don't understand
the distribution of circuit size very
well
and CSP
because it is defined approximately the
same thing like the circuit science so
so why is it possibility oh okay yeah I
mean a very good question I mean the
reason is that um they're approximately
the same in terms of being a polar
factor of each other but many of the
results are shown for Mk accountability
are about thresholds or complexities
that are very close to N so for example
complexity
um like n minus root n and there there
is no Clear Connection or application
for circuit size I mean if you showed
results for say k capital T complexity
is say n to the one third then it would
imply something for circuit complexity
but we show something for say k capital
B complexity n minus something small
that doesn't seem to have any direct
implications for certain sites yeah so
there are like various situations in
which you can compress strings a bit but
we don't know how to get small circuits
for them
um so if like a graph has like a large
key we can compress a little bit but it
doesn't mean that the graphql
specifically described as small circuits
so that's kind of like the intuition
behind this this first result here um
kind of
that's what we should watch it so yeah
that's yeah it's not gonna explain in
all cases
so one way to fix this situation would
be to show that um mktp uh approximating
mktp is equivalent to Computing it
exactly yeah yes right yes yes get rid
of all these fun factors and everything
report yeah yeah that's exactly right
and I think like for all these problems
like approximation how does
approximation of an exchange problems it
has this nice consequences
directly yeah so what kind of pattern
foreign
I think you need like for uh if you look
at strings of length n
um well it's it's a function of the of
the parameter so like maybe s squared or
something but maybe even a constant
Factor might be enough but not
completely sure
um so it's known that like if MCT is
like empty-hard under deterministrative
is not including either
so like is it just a similar thing mode
for mkta yeah
going here yes but under a specific kind
of reduction which um yeah I mean we
could use Randomness so we wanted a
longer yeah understood
um okay and then this was kind of like a
really nice recent result of Eric
um and ashwichi and a couple of students
who showed that MK Capital TP does not
have monomicized threshold of majority
circuits so you'd have like depth two
circuits where the top gate is a
threshold gate normally threshold gate
the bottom gates are majority Gates
um so this is um like the sort of the
frontier of um low depth complexity low
bounds right we don't know
um like low bounds against depth to
threshold circus we don't know if NP has
polynomial size depth to threshold
circuits but we do know that um uh yeah
even inner product doesn't have some
expression size threshold majority
circuits
um and one of the kind of projects in
metal complexity is try to transfer all
of these explicit hardness results to
the meta complexity problems to show
that they hold also from the matter
complexity problems and one class that
had sort of resisted this for a long
time is this class um um of threshold of
majority but um yeah this result
um cleverly sort of gets around that and
this is the again something we don't
know of mcsp we know it for Mk Capital
TP but we don't know it for mcsp so
essentially I think any like known kind
of low Bound for an explicit function
um circuit low bound we also know for Mk
Capital TP I think pretty much
um if you know of any counter examples
then uh yeah let me know but as far as
I'm aware you know all the low bounds
the mean of explicit functions
questions
uh is known to have lower bound yes yes
inner product is hard for that yes so
it's one gate of threshold and then
majority
yeah I mean that's more than two I mean
that's two they're both layers and
thresholds that's very hard but yeah
there's only one game uh it really said
this was like known in again like in the
late 80s
um it has a very simple proof for the
lower bound and yet we have an even bust
yes
but it was pretty extraordinary that we
kind of yeah just emerging a top gate
for majority of the threshold and it
doesn't seem like a security bar and
it's just that we don't know how to yeah
okay so um that's all I'm gonna say
about KCAL people that's it for now
um and now I'm going to talk about
characterization so something I said
that it doesn't in his paper is to give
new characterizations of value
complexity questions in terms of
variance of Commonwealth complexity
um okay so
um what's this about so
um well various Notions of resource
boundary moral complexity are useful in
characterizing various important open
questions and complexity Theory and the
hope is that these characterizations
because they're in terms of a few basic
Notions of complexity will lead to new
connections and approaches to these
questions and Eric's paper gives some
examples of such characterizations so I
just want to show you a couple of
examples and and what they look like
um so here's a characterization of um
the kind of the Assumption of the
statement that e is hard in no uniform
setting rather e requires exponential
size circuits
so let's just make a definition so let's
so we know what K Little T is um so
let's define k l t sub L of n so that's
just the smallest scality complexity of
any
um string in L right so the let's assume
for now that L is sort of non-empty at
every input length
um and if it doesn't we just ignore
those lengths and at the lens where it's
non-empty we take the the X with the
smaller scale and P complexity and
that's going to be this um this function
scalability is available
um and then Eric shows like um sort of a
series of equivalences
um so
um it shows that e requiring large
circles requiring circuits of
exponential size
um that was already known to be
equivalent to existence to random
generators through um the work of uh of
Russell and Avi victorson
um and uh what Eric shows is that this
equivalent with a couple of other
statements that are phrased in terms of
resource boundary control complexity so
one of these statements is that um for
all dense languages in um B slash poly
it's all dense languages meaning
languages that have at least two-thirds
of all strings of length n
um there is going to be some string with
small
um cable T complexity Auto log n kldt
complexity essentially the idea here is
that if you have a few random generator
then the seed will describe kind of um
some output of the some member of the
range which is in L right so so that's
the the idea here so
um uh so that turns out to be equivalent
to these two other items and then
there's this um kind of um statement
where
um there's some Epsilon such that if you
take any large enough n there's going to
be a string of that length such that
it's K capital T complexity and scalable
T complexity are very different so it's
K capital T complexity is exponential
and it's scalability complexity it
shouldn't be too hard to see that
um the klt complexity is um sort of
Atmos a k-cability complexity right K
Little T complexity you're kind of you
have a program running in time T and
you're just kind of adding log of the
time and with K capital T you you're
adding the time I mean of course the
sublinear time bound but um it's somehow
more restrictive and um in general yeah
strings with small kldt complexity
um small strings of small K Capital plus
you're going to have small T complexity
as well and this shows that the gap
between them is exactly the E requiring
sub-exp special size problem so
um e requires some special size almost
everywhere if an expression size almost
everywhere if and only if this holds for
um strings
um the sequence of strings that for
which this holds so so gaps between K
capital P and k l t respond to Circuit
no bonds and the proof essentially
combines the standardization result on
the processor victorson with the
relationships of non-uniformity
um and kind of like um and kind of
membership and exponential time to these
two complex team measures
um but yeah I think it's interesting
that you're now rephrasing things in
terms of these resource-bounded uh
measures
um and then
um he also has a result to characterize
next being easy so next having
polynomial size circuits so just as we
have the definition the previous slide
you can Define K capital P Isabella van
to be smallest K capital t x over X of
length n and L
and then um there's these kind of this
is amazing set of equalances that are
approved by
um Valentine Russell and Avi victorson
that next person P slash poly if and
only if next equals m a it's an only for
next search problems are solvent B slash
poly I mean this just means that there's
a polynomial size circuits which can
find
um sort of witnesses for um uh
exponential time verifiable relations
right so that's what solving the next
search problem means so this was known
and um and Eric showed that there's also
equivalent to something about K capital
t is available the K capital T sub L of
n is at most poly login
um and um if you're familiar with the
easy witness method so essentially this
is saying that um
um yeah like these things happen if only
if like the search problem has an easy
witness so witness is describable by a
circuit and and that's what um this
condition corresponds to so the
polynomial time uh computer language is
essentially a version of the verifier
for this next search problem and then
you want the witness for that to be
describable with by poly login but it's
by a circuit and that's exactly what it
means for the K capital T complexity to
be small
um so yeah so it's sort of like a new
perspective on these results on the easy
witness method um and the consequences
of that
and in general
um like what Eric does is that he kind
of his characterizations and there's
other kind of observation
characterizations he has there they
apply the concepts of commercial
complexity to various sort of important
techniques in uh see Randomness and
complexity so to harness based
dramatization results
um so you can think of all of these as
about compression somehow right
harness-based generalization results
show well if x is hard is not informally
hard then prgs exist but if x is easy I
mean X essentially corresponds to like
some Boolean function whose truth table
is computable and polynomial time the
size of the troops table right I mean a
language is an acts differently if it's
truth table is computer such as a truth
table and um the question is are such
strings compressible or not and by the K
capital T notion so either they're
compressible or else prgs exist so you
can think of
um Nissan witnessing um as being about
compressibility in this sense
um the natural proofs result of rosberg
essentially says the strong prgs exist
if one of your functions exist it's hard
to distinguish pressable strings from
incompressible ones that's um
essentially with an after-proof barrier
is saying and the easy witness method
which I just referred to
um and just personal paper bubble
Valentine and then in ikw it says that
either witnesses to search problems can
be compressed and that makes the search
from easy to solve just by searching
over these easy Witnesses
um for for a correct one or else um you
can kind of guess the solution to the
search problem and use that to
de-randomize by applying um iw97 and w94
um so this kind of win-win situation
either you can solve the search problem
efficiently by using easy Witnesses or
you can do randomize you can get some
sort of interesting determination
um so uh that is also about
compressibility in a different way
um so uh
um and so this kind of like language of
Resource One control complexity can be
used to kind of talk about all these
different proof techniques and
um and kind of provides a unifying
framework for these ideas and techniques
thank you
okay and and then I'd like to say a bit
about recent characterization so this
project of characterizing complexity
questions
um that um sort of Eric sort of
initiated I mean that's been quite
successful and um especially
um for cryptography and dramatization
but not in other places too
um so um there's this great result of uh
of new and pass
um um which can very influential and
recent connections of Commonwealth
complexity to
um
um to one-way functions they show that
one-way functions exist
um if and only if polynomial complexity
is hard on average uniform distribution
so that's a characterization too in
terms of
um the hardness of resource bounded
versions and there's under
characterization based on the hardness
on average even of whole number of
complexity to approximate
um then this password characterized
parallel cryptography by K capital T as
I already said so one-way functions in
nc1 we know that there exists definitely
one-way functions and nc0 exists by
famous result of Apple bombing and this
is the case if only if K capital t is
hard on average of the uniform
distribution
and then there's another kind of elegant
characterization that Lew and pass have
recently they characterize denization so
promise BP equals promised P they've
they have like American Plastic
condition that characterizes this
um essentially they say this happens if
and only if for every kind of um
um kind of machine M that's trying to
solve um the certain every probabilistic
machine M
um and um for like Z like a condition
that's that's long enough there's going
to be an X for which it's hard to
distinguish a case where K Little T of x
given Z is very large from the case
where it's very small so essentially BPP
equals P or plus b equals promise p is
characterized in terms of the hardness
of the matter complexity problem
um so that's like a really nice recent
result of Leon pass and um and even more
recently
um uh Eric and shuichi and Harsha they
have the scatterization of
non-attractive statistical zero
knowledge so for classroom cryptography
purely in terms of matter complexity in
terms of reductions to the Congress of
random strings and and
um I think this is kind of a project
that Eric has been kind of like thinking
about for a while about how to
characterize complexity classes in terms
of relationship to the random strings
and this is sort of like surprising and
very elegant characterization that they
have so this isn't quite character as a
complexity question but a characterizes
a class in terms of relationship to
commonweal complexity
um and there are several other results I
think even in the upcoming
um stock conferences a couple of other
characterizations so this is um this is
a very very active line of work to try
to find
um to kind of take complexity questions
or questions from Foundation photography
and
um and kind of understand how they
relate to these um fundamental meta
complexity Notions
okay so um now I'm gonna move on to the
low bound that uh that Eric shows and um
and and what followed on from that
um
so
um yeah you could ask well what kinds of
properties does this medical platform MK
Capital TP have I mean yeah how hard is
it
um and in this paper Eric observed that
MK capital T P does not have polynomial
size ac0 circuits right so it's um um
it's sort of hard for uh for ac0 I mean
you'd expect it's very very hard you'd
expect it's it's NP hard but what can we
show unconditionally
um and he showed this and the reason why
this is interesting is that like
standard techniques for showing lower
bounds like random restrictions don't
seem to apply so easily to meta
complexity problems so
um you can't just like take random
restrictions method or method and use
them where complexity problems they
don't work
um you need a different approach
um and the approach that often is very
effective is an approach basically
Randomness um so um what Eric does is he
looks at Nissan's generator which Maps
poly login random bits to ensue random
bits and this is known to be secure
against ac0
um and um The crucial observation that
Eric made was this genetically
implemented so that for each seed Z of
set land poly log n the output is going
to have small K capital T complexity so
um
it's actually clear that it's going to
have small K Little T complexity order
poly log n and this is something that
Marius Zim and used to show that MK
little TP is not an ac0 but then Eric
saw that in fact these designs and
Nissans generator can be implemented
very efficiently and you have this
property
um so the one hand outputs of the
generator have small K capital T
complexity on the other hand random
strings have very large K Capital
complexity close to N
um so you can think of K capital T
complexity as like a distinguisher
between pseudom strings and random
strings it can be used to distinguish
Uranus strings from random strings but
that of course means that you can't
compute it in AC 0 right because this is
an unconditionally secure generator
against ac0 so we can't really compute K
capital in s0 because we know the K
capital is a good distinguisher
um so yeah so this is sort of like a
nice proof but more importantly it kind
of like it's a paradigm can be applied
elsewhere
um what Eric says in this paper is well
by theorem 15 in the theorem that I just
said um um neither of these classes so
this is just like maybe for now let's
think of it as a different way of saying
m k l t p and this is like MK Capital PP
these aren't annoying from ac0 and I'm
unable to find a construct any other low
bounds on the complexity of these
problems um other conditional ones
um but then in future work this was sort
of approached and there's like various
um sort of um kinds of progress on it so
let me just explain what the Paradigm is
again and kind of abstract it out a bit
so
um the prg Paradigm is that you have a
generator with some non-trivial seed
length s of N and output length n you
want it to be secure against a Class C
of circuits right so that's that's what
you want
um uh and in some cases you have that
unconditionally in other cases not and
let's to generalize it say that it has
the following property I mean
um you want the outputs of the generator
have small complexity right so there's
some complexity measure mu so you want
for each seed for each Z of length s of
n then mu of G of Z is small is that
more stress of time let's say
then you can in fact prove both
unconditional low bounds against weak
losses of circuits and conditional low
bonds meaning hardness results
um uh using this this Paradigm for
unconditional low bonds you um show you
construct some G that's unconsciously
secure against C and having this
property and that would imply that mu p
is not in C so mu could be K Little T K
capital T circuit size KS Space Bound
complexity anything you like
um and that's just by the same argument
I mentioned before
um
um and then you have these conditional
lower bounds like if for each F so the
Nissan reason generator is a hardness
based generator right so for each
function
um you have like a you can instantiate
the generator and get a generated G sub
F and you have the property that if f is
hard for for C then the generator is
good and then you can think of this as
like a reduction in a way and so
um if G sub f is secure again C when f
is not in C and this is a reduction then
it turns out that ASC reducible time P
so essentially you can use this
generator based approach to reduce a
complexity class to mup in cases where
we don't have unconditional
um
um generators but just hardness-based
generators
and both of these sort of like um kind
of ideas have been used a lot so um
there's a very influential paper that um
Eric Michal and others wrote very soon
after he uh he published this paper
where they showed like a slew of final
results for Mk little PP for space
bounded version
um so
um the easiest state is that it's this
class is uh that this language is X part
and a p slash poly reductions just by
instantiating the Paradigm from before
um but in fact they have much stronger
harness results under NP reductions and
and under zpp reduction so the space
bounded version and so on so they're
really kind of
um like use this very effectively and it
can also show that mcsp is hard for
polynomial time on nc1 reductions by
using the same Paradigm and there's
several other results but here's just a
couple of them and in terms of
unconditional low bounds that's a sort
of like I'm saying before we can now
recover almost all sort of explicit low
bounds we have yeah
um so uh yeah and then as I was saying
before
um almost all explicit load bands we
have we can recover for these medical
basket problems um so um uh so this is
shown uh it was used to show the mcsp
doesn't have some product size formulas
which is not quite optimal
um because we know almost cubic low
bounce and MK Capital PP is not a0 more
P
um but then um
um yeah balancing and others show that
you have almost optimal results the
mcspr some cubic size for the subratic
size launching programs so software
special size ac0 serbians and this
exploits this powerful generators and
browser Mecca and Zuckerman and kind of
applies this Paradigm to that generator
so essentially no low bounce gives you
Randomness that matches the low bound
and from the C Randomness you can
extract low bounds for the web
complexity problems so it's kind of
indirect um you don't apply the robot
techniques directly but go through see
Randomness um and that works
um and then the more recent paper
um of uh
shuichi and others shows that mcsp
doesn't have an alternative branching
programs the size and 1.5 so here again
it's close to what we know in general
for explicit problems
yeah so I've been various lines of work
related to this um
and then
um yeah so identifies interesting open
problems and directions so let me just
maybe quote the paper here so uh I mean
Eric says uh yeah it's been very useful
in attacking a wide variety of problems
in Computer Science and Mathematics it
has not found much application yet in
the field of the randomization
um
um so it just hope that the difference
provided here will be useful from
getting new lines of attack on these
problems and indeed like the leopard
characterization that I mentioned or
even the work of Lydia and Roy which is
kind of related to work complexity does
sort of um
um yeah is implicitly kind of talking
about from overall complexity and then
he says in particular scenes what likely
to me they're better balanced improved
RK capital P which we saw before
um I'm sure that uh there are new and
interesting applications going to be
discovered and since these Notions have
tried connections with theory of natural
proofs I think it's possible that
investigation of these questions the
application only if the study of
dramatization but throughout complexity
Theory and hopefully the semester some
sort of uh evidence of the um of the
foresight and this in the statement
so um before concluding um yeah maybe
I'd I'd like to say just a bit about uh
Eric other aspects of Eric apart from
his uh um his research so there's sort
of a dozen papers I mentioned here
there's like a dozen more more recent
papers I mean it's clearly done a lot on
meta complexity
um but he has of course all these other
facets to him
um as sort of a colleague as an actor as
a friend
um we all know how witty and
entertaining a speaker he is from his
carp lecture where he uses these
uniquely deep voice and he's training
and theater to great effect
um so we know um how great he is as a
citizen the community I mean how
conscientious it is with his duties
whether it's program committees or
editing or reviewing
um and I think he's one of the first
people we go to for advice if we have
kind of questions about some aspect of
the community
um and he's also a great mentor not just
to um to people he works with but to um
to to younger researchers in general I
mean when I was a early graduate student
Eric was one of the most approachable
people and I know he kind of like talks
to and cares about the most Junior
researchers just as much as more senior
ones
so um yeah it's uh
it's great that uh I mean Eric is
retiring like at the top of his game in
a sense because he has like great recent
work and characterizing statistical zero
knowledge
um an approach to MP versus L um I mean
I wonder if he can resist actually
thinking about meta complexity a bit in
his retirement uh but even if he doesn't
think of medical black student medical
must you'll be thinking of him
[Applause]
foreign
I mean is there any yeah I mean the
problem for actually attacking its
hardness yeah it did take some effort
but then it turned out that like all the
normal balance could be shown off the
biggest no complexion problems right so
um uh I guess it kind of like quite a
different perspective I mean it might be
that these characterizations are
together they actually barriers are
proving these results so that might be
another kind of perspective I mean the
stacks have assumption barriers
um but I think I mean there's already
been kind of quite a bit of progress on
understanding these measures and also
connecting them to like other Notions of
complexity I think sort of like meta
complexity will sort of doing its own
thing it's sort of very isolated and I
think connecting it to other areas of
complexity Theory I mean to pcps for
example in the organization so that's I
think there's quite a lot to be done
there as well
um
um because it's not perspective
compressions
I think another answer might be if you
look at some of the words that shurichi
hirahara has done
approaching questions that and the
statement of them have nothing to do
with meta complexity with using these
meta complexity tools to to make
significant progress
no more questions let's stay in trouble
again
in about 10 minutes